Що таке українська література?
Чи відома точна дата, з якої починається її відлік?
Як на її формування впливали численні заборони?
Без яких постатей українську літературу
неможливо уявити?
У цій розповіді нас частково поведе хронологія,
а десь — важливість теми,
її унікальність та яскравість.
Інколи нашим провідником стане серце.
Те саме, яке «диктує», «кохається»,
«мерзне» та «щемить».
А інколи ми будемо йти за розумом та інтелектом,
бо хоч століттями українську літературу
забороняли та утискали,
вона була і є повноцінною,
самодостатньою та оригінальною.
Для початку треба уточнити значення слова «Русь».
Сучасна українська традиція розрізняє
поняття «руський» та «російський»,
тоді як у сучасній російській мові
різниці між ними немає.
З погляду історичної об’єктивності
«руський» — це етнонім на позначення
середньовічних українців.
На Заході в Середні віки українські
землі у їх сукупності називали Руссю.
Назва ж «Україна» в локальному
значенні «козацька земля»
вживалася десь із середини XVII століття.
Недарма Михайло Грушевський
для увиразнення тяглості
між минулим та сучасністю
використовував назву «Україна-Русь».
І якщо назву «Україна» вперше зафіксовано
у Київському літописі в 1187 році,
то повсюдно вона закріпиться
лише на початку ХХ століття.
У Х–XVII століттях українська книжність
розвивалася у рамках церковних інституцій.
Тож література того часу мала чітко окреслену функцію,
яка зафіксована ще у «Повісті временних літ»:
«Книги ж учать і наставляють нас на путь покаяння,
і мудрість бо, і стриманість
здобуваємо ми із словес книжних».
Існування в християнській парадигмі позначається
і на жанровому розмаїтті, і на назвах книг.
Наприклад, «вертоград» –
слово, яким називали сад,
а в символічному значенні —
образ Небесного Граду.
Впливало християнство і на зміст.
Часто пошук алегорій і символів
формував оптику розуміння світу.
Наприклад, автор трактату «Фізіолог»
описував як справжніх тварин,
так і фантастичних істот.
Пригоди і тих, і інших були
позбавлені подробиць,
характерних для книг про тварин,
проте повнилися біблійними алегоріями.
У ті часи і сам автор сприймався
не як письменник, а радше як той,
хто втілює Божу волю.
На зміну давній літературі з усіма її химерами
приходить епоха книгодрукування.
Хвилі ренесансної культури,
докотившись до України,
запускають процеси національного відродження.
Так, у 1483 році виходить друком книга
ректора престижного Болонського
університету Юрія Котермака.
І хоча це був астрологічний памфлет
із досить специфічною назвою —
«Прогностична оцінка поточного 1483 року»,
саме цей твір став першою друкованою книгою,
яку написав українець.
Далі — більше.
У 1491 році в Кракові з’явилися
перші кириличні друки.
І нарешті у 1574 році у Львові
Іван Федорович створив
першу на українських землях
друковану книгу «Апостол»
і перший серед східних слов’ян буквар.
А далі на зламі XVI—XVII століть
українську культуру полонить бароко.
Дослівно «бароко» означає
перлину неправильної форми.
Тобто щось коштовне та екстравагантне.
І в тогочасній Україні бароко проявляється всюди:
в церковній архітектурі,
в живописі, в одязі, в мові.
Не залишається осторонь і література,
в якій традиційне домінування
духовного складника химерно
сполучається з грою
античними міфологемами.
У поезії виникає силабічний вірш,
для якого характерна
однакова кількість складів у рядку.
Автори граються з формами,
експериментують з віршами.
І перший з-поміж рівних тут —
Іван Величковський.
Ось як він зашифровує своє ім’я
у виділених літерах.
Все більшої популярності
набувають історичні пісні і думи.
Не дивно, що саме в цей період стає
дедалі важливішою постать кобзаря,
який для української літератури й
свідомості стане справжнім архетипом.
І якщо ми вже заговорили про архетипи,
саме в період бароко,
у 1715 році, фіксується перша згадка про гайдамаків.
А ще у добу бароко шириться використання мови
«прОстої», або «руської»,
яка відвойовує текстовий простір у «слов’яноруської»,
тобто в української версії церковнослов’янської мови.
Усупереч цим процесам у 1720 році вийде указ Петра І
про заборону друкувати книги українською мовою.
Мине ще пів століття, і в 1775 році
російські війська зруйнують Запорізьку Січ.
У наступний період в українській
літературі яскраво проявляється
неконтрольована стихія бурлеску.
XIX століття доводить:
низьке здатне виражати високі істини.
Сміх починає містити навіть святість.
Питання, яке ставив Григорій Сковорода, —
чи сміявся коли Христос? —
дістає ствердну відповідь.
Ключовою постаттю цього періоду
стає Іван Котляревський,
який береться за ремейк Вергілієвої «Енеїди».
Цей твір назавжди утвердить
думку про те, що сміх —
невилучна риса національного
характеру українців.
І вибір епігонів «Енеїди» —
писати в такій манері
та ще й українською мовою —
сигналізував відмежування
від всеімперського контексту.
Стихія українського сміху
вривається в Російську імперію —
Гоголь учить Росію сміятися.
Не сміхом єдиним.
У XIX столітті також постають
основні стовпи українського канону —
літературного та національного.
Це Тарас Шевченко, Леся Українка, Іван Франко.
Тарас Шевченко ще за життя стає Кобзарем —
людиною з народу і для народу,
живим втіленням колективної пам’яті,
борцем за правду й справедливість.
Іванові Франку дістається роль Каменяра –
реаліста, матеріаліста й атеїста.
Людини суспільно заангажованої,
з чіткою громадянською позицією.
А ще поета, прозаїка, перекладача, вченого.
Для сотень масок у Франка
було близько ста псевдонімів.
Нарешті Леся Українка — освічена,
шляхетна, Дочка Прометея на всі часи.
Втілення нескореності та сили духу.
Переконлива феміністка.
Ці три фігури такі значущі й вагомі
для української літератури,
що й донині залишаються байдужими
до різноманітних спроб нових поколінь десакралізувати,
розвінчати, скинути з п’єдесталів.
І якщо ми вже заговорили про канон,
український літературний іконостас
далеко не «триєдиний».
Навіть без Гоголя в ньому достатньо
непроминальних постатей та творів,
які дають зрозуміти, наскільки
розмаїта українська література.
Наприклад, «Кайдашева сім’я»
Івана Нечуя-Левицького
вже два віки тримає марку архетипу
української родинної історії.
Історії, актуальної і донині.
Або, наприклад, Ольга Кобилянська,
яка на новому витку досліджень і дискусій
про витоки українського фемінізму
досі розширює свою читацьку аудиторію.
Так само, як і Михайло Коцюбинський,
який виринає то в контексті інтерпретації його повісті
«Тіні забутих предків»
Сергієм Параджановим і Юрієм Іллєнком,
то як майстер позачасової психологічної прози.
Або «Місто» Валер’яна Підмогильного —
яскравий доробок урбаністичної романістики,
який доводить, що українська література –
це не тільки про село.
Окремо варто згадати українські
20-ті XX століття та їхнє розмаїття.
Це епоха розквіту українського детективу,
любовного роману і
любовної прози, фантастики,
жіночої прози, а також тревел-репортажистики.
В український контекст
повертаються імена і цілі жанри,
які заперечують умовну
неповноту української літератури.
На міжнародному рівні нарешті
починає утверджуватися таке явище,
як український авангард.
Часто  українська література
формується в ситуації боротьби,
кристалізується через спротив.
Вона така як є, бо долає заборони,
репресії та колоніальний вплив.
Наприклад, Валуєвський циркуляр —
цензурна заборона друкувати
українськомовну духовну і
популярну освітню літературу.
Та Емський указ — заборона друкувати і
ввозити з-за кордону будь-яку
українськомовну літературу та
українські переклади з іноземних мов.
З розпадом Російської імперії мало що змінилося.
Радянська система невтомно і
цілеспрямовано піддавала арештам
та репресіям українських митців.
Покоління українських дисидентів
вимріювали свою Україну,
піддаючись тортурам каральних органів
та ризикуючи життям.
Один із найпотужніших
українських поетів – Василь Стус –
був закатований у таборах 1985 року.
При цьому остання його прижиттєва
публікація поезій в Радянському Союзі
була в журналі «Донбас» на початку 1966 року.
Наступна – за чотири роки після його смерті – 1989 року.
Це було буквально вчора.
Ще живі ті, хто товаришував із поетом.
Ще живі ті, хто закатував його.
Через постійні заборони,
через історичну турбулентність, врешті-решт
через те, що життя —
це завжди пошук кращої долі,
українська література творилася не тільки в Україні.
У 1920-х роках, після хвилі еміграції,
пов’язаної з поразкою
національно-визвольних змагань,
сформувалася «празька школа».
Саме тоді увиразнюється найважливіша риса
української літератури в еміграції:
вона стає альтернативою
радянській офіційній літературі,
оскільки не слідує за єдиним каноном соцреалізму,
всотує тенденції світової актуальної літератури
та посідає критичну позицію щодо радянської системи.
Потужна хвиля українських
письменників-емігрантів
була спричинена Другою світовою війною.
В таборах здебільшого американської окупаційної зони,
де перебувало близько двухсот тисяч українців,
утворюється МУР –
Мистецький український рух.
Він проіснував три роки.
За цей час було опубліковано
понад 1200 книжок і памфлетів.
У часи МУРу написані чи вперше опубліковані
«Тигролови» Івана Багряного,
«Доктор Серафікус» і «Без ґрунту»
Віктора Домонтовича,
«Ост» Уласа Самчука.
У 1950-х роках формується
нове літературне утворення –
Нью-Йоркська група.
Вона складалася з людей,
які народилися в Україні,
але освіту здобули на Заході
вже після війни.
Ці люди асоціювали себе з Нью-Йорком,
а відповідно —
з динамікою, космополітичністю,
мистецьким авангардом
та захопленням стихією великого міста.
У 1961 році у Мюнхені був
заснований журнал «Сучасність»,
який протягом 30 років видавався
у Німеччині, потім — у США.
Журнал став важливою платформою
для українських інтелектуалів діаспори.
Амбасадорами України стали
Український вільний університет у Мюнхені,
Канадський інститут українських студій,
Український науковий інститут
Гарвардського університету.
Ось що сказав про українську літературу в еміграції
українсько-американський славіст Юрій Шевельов:
«Якщо не могло бути батьківщини
на географічній мапі,
ми могли збудувати батьківщину
в наших душах».
І збудували.
У символічному полі початком
відліку українського постмодернізму,
за однією з версій,
стає Чорнобильська катастрофа.
Бо з відчуттям кінця світу та історії
українська література намагається
боротися іронією та
створенням нового підходу
до розуміння і ролі письменника,
і того, що таке література.
У середині 80-х формуються нові літугрупування.
Заснована Юрієм Андруховичем,
Віктором Небораком
та Олександром Ірванцем
за рік до Чорнобильської катастрофи,
група «Бу-Ба-Бу»
(Бурлеск-Балаган-Буфонада)
суттєво доклалася до розвитку іронії,
як зброї проти усталених кліше та обмежень .
Зокрема, Підскарбій «Бу-Ба-Бу»
Олександр Ірванець зробить одним зі
своїх ключових інструментів
знущання з соцреалістичного канону.
А Патріарх «Бу-Ба-Бу» Юрій Андрухович
напише «Рекреації» та «Московіаду»  —
два важливих тексти для розуміння українського
постколоніального дискурсу.
У ще жорсткішій формі вибухне сміх
у п’єсах Леся Подерв’янського,
чиїми місткими й універсальними
формулами опису реальності
ми користується донині.
«Вони шукають те, чого нема,
щоб довести, що його не iснує».
Але за точку відліку сучасної української
літератури можна взяти не тільки Чорнобиль.
Такою точкою могло би бути
заснування журналу «Четвер» у 1989 році.
Він зібрав спільноту талановитих
авторів, сприяючи формуванню,
так званого Станіславського феномену.
Або можна стартувати від 1996 року,
з публікації роману «Польові дослідження
з українського сексу» Оксани Забужко.
Але як би ми не рахували,
Україна 90-х, Україна нульових —
це вільний від ідеології простір
гри зі старими колоніальними міфами,
що підпорядковує їх
власним естетичним завданням.
Іронія, пародія, карнавал — наше все.
Плюс трішки неконтрольованої
стихії українського бурлеску.
2014 рік змінює все.
З Революцією гідності, анексією Криму
та гібридною російсько-українською
війною відбуваються кілька
радикальних трансформацій у суспільстві,
культурі і, звичайно, літературі.
Письменники йдуть на війну.
А ті захисники України, які, ймовірно,
ніколи не спробували б себе
в літературі, трансформують
свій досвід у тексти.
Найцікавіші літературні явища
останніх років так чи так пов’язані
з осмисленням війни та її наслідків.
Окремо стоять книжки,
що у XXI столітті вмонтовуються
в традицію табірної прози.
Реальність така насичена подіями,
що останні роки стають розквітом
українського нон-фікшну й есеїстики.
Українці дедалі більше усвідомлюють
свою ідентичність,
тож цікавляться своєю історією,
мистецтвом, традиціями
та сучасністю у всіх її проявах.
Після Майдану формуються нові культурні інституції.
На книжковий ринок приходять
нішеві видавництва.
Починається активніша апробація
нових форм побутування книжки.
По всій країні виникають
нові літературні фестивалі.
Є й проблеми.
Скажімо, майже всі державні інституції,
створені після Майдану,
перебувають під величезним зовнішнім тиском
і спробою ручного керування процесами.
Та попри химери політики й економіки
спалах української літератури триває.
І якщо цей процес не перерветься,
то вже дуже скоро з’явиться покоління,
якому не треба буде починати спочатку.
Вони зможуть прожити довге і щасливе
життя, втіливши все задумане.
А ще в них будуть читачі, які відкриють
для себе українську літературу.
І приймуть її як своє,
відчуваючи, що нам є чим пишатись,
є про що мріяти.
Розуміючи, що нам є про що пам’ятати.
Бо українська література — це серце
та розум, які  б’ються разом,
працюють разом, пульсують разом,
разом створюють цілі світи.